we're scared of zombies but at the end
of the day maybe it is we who we should
fear not the zombies themselves I'm
going with
both I'm already scared of us if zombies
show up I'm going be scared of them
too to me the zombie apocalypse is the
people who drive the trucks that bring
the food from the Farms to the grosser
they're taken out zombies don't drive
trucks so a zombie apocalypse is not
fundamentally different from a pandemic
right we saw some of this at the
beginning of coid the supply chains were
broken forget the zombies ask yourself
how dependent are you on civilization
itself and then consider the zombie
apocalypse and you're the first to go
well there you go there's something good
to think about during this season
zombies and the breakdown of society as
a whole I like